don't go broke trying to look rich
that's one thing everybody's doing right
now they're broke trying to look rich
I'm constantly in a crisis to get to the
next version of me you must become
evangelical about your cause and your
mission one of the great evangelists of
all time is Steve Jobs the motivation
was the top ten with believe nation
he's had my leg and here's my tape of
his top ten rose to success vol five
enjoy I can't tell you why I'm this way
but I do believe it was baseball I never
took it personally when a coach said
you're dropping your shoulder in others
because of athletics when I guy said
spread your right leg out your legs are
too close together never thought I suck
I can't hit I wanted to know how to hit
better I wanted to know how to throw
better and so for me personally I'm
constantly in a crisis to get to the
next version of me it's not like I'd
like to I wish I only would like to
probably have a little more peace in my
life I am in a crisis to get the next
version of me and so the guy sitting in
front of you right now if I come back in
a year and I'm just the same exact
person with the same thoughts same ideas
same ways of delivering them this was a
wasted year of my life right so I want
to know how to get to that next version
of me and so for those of you that
struggle with taking criticism
I get asked of how important is it to
you to grow cuz you were put on earth to
grow to contribute to serve to help you
were in your way and the current version
of you is perfect as it stands right now
but it will be inferior next year you're
perfect as you are now especially you
ladies listening to this there's all
this a messaging you're not this you're
not smart enough women are too dominant
then they're a diva right or you're not
beautiful enough ladies men you - you
are perfect as you exist right now but
that version of you isn't sufficient
next year you gotta be crazy hungry
crisis to get to that next version of
you I want the data I want the input I
want the information I want the feedback
to get to the next version of me
regardless of how it emotionally makes
me feel I'm like driven by that without
that information why am i living
rule number two persuade people if I
could go back and you could only give me
one skill to begin with and I had to
build from all of it I can tell you for
sure what it would be for me and that
would be the ability to influence so
it's the ability to persuade people
without that skillset the vast majority
of my wealth does not exist if you can't
persuade people
if you can't influence people to make
decisions that are in their own best
interest but that also grow your
business your brand your company your
network
you can't ever become successful one
thing that everybody I know that's a
leader and everything they do can do is
persuade people now I watch people do
that in all different types of way some
do it through intimidation some through
do it through force some do it through
humor some do it through persuasive
strategies transfer of energy you name
it but all leaders can persuade all
successful people can get people to make
decisions in their own best interests
that also get them to participate with
their company it's the number one skill
that I see most people not spending the
most time on is their ability to
communicate their ability to persuade
people and because they're constantly
trying to go to a different course or
they think that somehow if their product
is good enough or they get the right
sales pitch that somehow they're gonna
win but the fact of the matter is you've
got to become a better person
rule number three don't feel broke
trying to look rich don't go broke
trying to look rich that's one thing
everybody's doing right now they're not
broke trying to look rich so here's I am
I don't care where you put the money you
know there's guys out there saying
should be real estate should be the
stock market if you don't save money
when you're broke this is the thing no
one's telling you if you don't save
money when you're broke I'm talking
about ten bucks a month twenty bucks a
month the crazy belief system in the
world is that you will save it once you
make more if you have a habit of
spending you will spend more when you
make more I know a lot of people who
make a lot of money who have a
Lamborghini or a car or a house that are
dead broke dead broke you all would be
shocked by who's really rich and by
who's really broke yeah you - shocked
because you either are a spender or you
are a saver when I was 26 years old I
made seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars that year and I was living in a
$750 a month apartment okay I saved and
save you know it's really rule number
four touch your dreams your mind
gravitates towards which it is most
familiar with and so if you're really
familiar with what you're worried about
what your problems are and your fears
are and that becomes your dominating
thinking I know you've all heard this
but here's the reason why your mind
loves what's familiar okay and so if you
don't go touch dreams for example just
experience it for a second for example
we would go down one
every eight weeks if I did well in
business we really knocked it out we
could find a deal I had 200 bucks we'd
go to the ritz-carlton or some hotel
ocean and for one day oceanfront feel
like what it felt like to valet your car
right walk in the lobby mister my lat
welcome back right she'd go get a
massage I play a little bit of golf and
just for that day I touch the dream and
then maybe we do it again in a month or
two and again in a month just little
taste of it my mind began to begin to
become familiar with it and more crazy I
started to kind of trick myself into
thinking I belong to there because we
never end up anywhere we don't believe
we don't belong and then we're not
familiar with so there's these things
you'd like to do in your life either
visually seeing them over and over again
and repeating those images to yourself
that's powerful but a double whammy is
to not only repeat them and see them but
to go to see there's one thing that's a
visual stimulus in your brain that makes
you want to do something the triple
whammy is if you could see it touch it
feel it and smell it if you allow all
your senses to experience something it
becomes far more familiar to your brain
and so I'm a massive massive advocate of
touching a dream in any form you can get
it the best of which is actually going
and experiencing it short-term you begin
to believe you belong there you're a
little bit better and so I you will not
probably produce many things in your
life that you've not visited either
mentally or literally thousands of times
and so if you want to end up somewhere
you better be visiting them those could
be dreams visions but the most important
thing is if you could actually more
powerful is you go touch them short-term
massive difference drive by the
neighborhood see the cars if you want to
spend your life and service for your
church or your community take a day out
every month and actually do it know what
it feels like for an afternoon to feed
the homeless or to do and you begin to
love it and feel it and believe you
belong there
more and more chance that you'll be able
to do that full-time someday in others
2.2 54 series the link is in the
description below it's free and you'll
love it so if you want to change your
life my friends you got to change your
physiology and you got to change your
focus the reason people aren't patient
is they value other people's opinions
too much you have to go build
self-confidence rule number 5 become
evangelical about your cause one thing I
want to challenge you to be is a leader
of your business whether it's just your
leader of one which is you as a
salesperson or a leader of ten as a team
or a company of twenty five thousand
employees is you must become evangelical
about your cause in your mission the
greatest businesspeople have an
evangelical property about them their
evangelizing all the time they're
propagating the the strengths the
benefits of their business of their
mission of their Klaus one of the great
evangelists of all time as Steve Jobs is
a great book written by a guy named Guy
Kawasaki many years ago called selling
the dream and in that book he talks
about the way that Steve Jobs sold the
dream of Apple and he literally called
him an evangelist for the cause there's
a great story in that book about Steve
Jobs when he was recruiting he knew he
needed to have a CEO of his company and
he wanted to have the best and at that
time there was a man named Scully who
was the head of Pepsi and Jobs was this
young kid in his 20s trying to recruit
this executive who'd made millions of
dollars and he couldn't get him and he
couldn't get him and he couldn't get him
and finally he gets the voicemail back
in those days the answering machine
actually of Scully and he says listen
listen man when you're tired of selling
sugar water to kids over there at Pepsi
and you want to come change the world
frickin call me back and we'll do it
together oh man he hangs up right
he was Evangel about the cause sugar
water in Pepsi changed the world at
Apple right and Scully was making
millions of dollars they see over the
most powerful companies in the world
looks to his wife and she says I think
he's right we aren't changing the world
and it was that one cause oriented
evangelical phone call from Steve Jobs
and it exuded out of his pores every
stage speech he gave everyone on one
every board meeting when he'd meet with
their software engineers when he'd meet
with the programmers he was always
evangelical internally and externally
and built a culture of one of the
greatest movements of all time in the
history of business rule number six use
your time better me tell you one thing
I've noticed about all the maxout
performers that I've interviewed on my
program that I've known throughout my
life for the last thirty years really in
business sports entertainment politics
you name it the elite performers look at
time and use time completely differently
than the people who perform at an
average level the first thing I want to
tell you
about people who win who max out they
are in a much bigger hurry than the
people who are average and I'm not
kidding you when I say this they're in a
bigger hurry to get to their destination
to get to their outcome their pace is
faster they walk faster they talk faster
and their expectation where they're
gonna arrive at their destination is
sooner this may seem like a very small
subtle thing but I want you to evaluate
how big of a hurry are you in because
there's something to be said about how
close you think you are to a goal and
how fast you will run to get to the
finish line let me give an example of
that if you and I started out right now
and we had a 26 mile marathon to run
right in our minds it was 26 miles we're
gonna race each other we would pace
ourselves at a certain speed in order to
maintain that speed because of the
duration of the run so those a marathon
we'd jog wouldn't we pretty slowly you
certainly wouldn't sprint 26 miles and
so because the destination because the
finish line is so far away our pace or
our hurry is limited based on how far
away we think we are or when we'll
arrive there but if you and I were to
run a 100-yard dash with the pace be the
same because the finish line is so much
closer we'd run full-speed from the
minute we took off wouldn't we because
of the proximity of how close the finish
line is the people that win in life
don't necessarily have more vision than
you see it's not a lack of vision always
that means that you are going to lose
it's a lack of a type of vision which is
depth perception you think you're
further away from the outcome and so you
pace yourself like it and you jog all
the time throughout your life the people
that win may have a bigger vision but
they have accurate depth perception they
understand how close their goals are how
close their outcome is and they're
constantly in a sprint to get there
throughout their day
that means consequently they get started
earlier and they finish later they get
up earlier throughout the day they're in
a bigger hurry to get to the places they
need to be because the finish line and
their mind is so much closer I cannot
emphasize this enough to you is just the
pace and the way time shrinks for elite
performers compared to the average I'm
telling you the average performer can
say
the same things read the same books have
the same schedule yet the person who
isn't a bigger hurry throughout the day
ends up winning the day winning the week
winning the month winning the year and
winning the life rule number seven take
action I know for me taking action
really builds confidence you know
sometimes you almost have to fake it
until you make it if you just is
confident you start to feel confident
you think that that's percent you can't
if I say this all the time I can't teach
you how to steer a parked car right you
have to be in motion you have to be
moving and people wonder have I really
made a decision the real way we know if
you've made a decision to make a change
is that it's followed up with immediate
massive action as you said and that's
the thing I think there's a lot of
people invested in personal development
to make it more complicated than it
really is as if there's these secrets
you know whether it's the authors of the
books or mentors or whoever it is in
fact even you might be invested if if
you can make it yourself believe that
winning is complex because really
complexity is the enemy of execution
right but if you can make yourself think
it's complex then it's really not your
fault you haven't won yet because you're
missing something rather than it
probably being what it really is is that
you're unwilling or avoiding the work
you need to do to really go build your
company or build your field force or
build your body or build your life and
so it's being able to simplify things
and really know that there is no key to
really winning the key is the hard work
and keeping things as simple as you can
from the study success so you are one of
the greatest not just influencers but
and speakers publicly thank you that or
in the world coming right now for those
that you know are looking to step up and
become a brand he right now they have
that desire they want to become speakers
you know what how do you master that
craft of being able to get into a flow
and really connect with your audience
watch the people that are out there how
do they deliver their message where do
they hold their hands I'm not saying you
should copy people I'm saying study it
study there I studied because there's
pre social media
I studied preachers on TV this day I
watched stand-up comedians constantly
I'm addicted to it because they're funny
and I watch how they roll out of line I
watch how they deliver a message i watch
do they walk when they talk do they stop
when they're making the important point
how do they use their hands so they
raise their voice do they lower their
voice how comfortable are they
silence so I watch people who can
communicate all the time the separation
is always in the preparation so my
confidence always comes from how
prepared I am when I speak I told you
earlier I need to prepare for tomorrow I
know what I'm gonna say but I've got to
really prepare my confidence the
separation for me comes into preparation
well then I have a strong why left to my
own devices right if you just left me
like what I'd like to do
I hate man I have no problem laying
around I like sleep I got people think
they meet people like you know they're
like they're robots they're other
life-forms they're just different than
me
no we build habits rituals and
disciplines that serve us ok now part of
those habits rituals and disciplines
have sort of turned me into a more
confident person there's no question
about that
so my standards are mandatory because
you get your standards right and so the
reason my standards are set whole so
high is because I don't want to leave it
up to my own devices right my standard
is one more minute on the treadmill my
standard is one more person I can reach
that day one more phone call one more
something and so for me I raise them
every single year but the way I get to
do it as I link it to my reasons and so
goals are really empty to me I have a
thing on goal-setting but like my big
thing is that you show me someone with
compelling emotional gigantic reasons
I'll show you someone who's changing
their standards all day long so like
give you one quick version that you not
heard before one of the reasons I'm
relatively fit is not just peak State
myelin uncle and my family that died at
50 years old of a heart attacks my
godfather my dad's only brother I kind
of resembled him and I look like him a
lot so on the way back from his funeral
my reticular activating on heart attacks
on the TV screen on the airplane I'm
listening to music is the Oprah Winfrey
Show she's going through a new heart
scan hmm I've unplugged my headphones
plugged into the airplane one there's
some of this new scan at cedars-sinai
that at that time was new it could read
the plaques in your arteries the
calcifications without going you know
really invasively
I scheduled it I went in I had a
world-class doctor who understood
reasons and levers instead of just
prescribing clues but when we coach
people you need to do this you need to
do this the doctors do it take this pill
take this he understood leverage and
reasons what you do is you take the scan
then you go to lunch you come back
the scan I went which I had a burrito I
came back and I'm in the law when I walk
in I sit down the doctor comes up and he
says oh my I can't believe these
arteries are in that young body
got my attention we walk back in we sit
down he could still go you need Crestor
eat clean get out of here is know what
an average doctor does right
no wired me with huge reasons he goes
let me ask you a question I heard your
wife's pregnant you have I said I have a
son and he says do you want to be there
when he graduates from high school to be
there for that day I said yes sir yeah
he goes your wife's pregnant what do you
have it I said a daughter this is where
you get a dad he goes she was six months
pregnant he goes do you would you like
to walk her down the aisle on her
wedding day are you okay that it's some
other man I went what the Sun this skin
right like and he goes I want to be very
clear with you if you keep going down
the road you're going there'll be some
other man with your son at graduation
high school and a strangers walking your
daughter down the aisle that's not even
born yet on her wedding day and I went
boom and he goes but if you do exactly
what I tell you to do you'll be there
and so to this day brother there are
mornings when I wake up not every
morning I don't want to go to the gym I
go Bella's wedding Bella's wedding
Bella's wedding so my standards are high
because of my big old reasons other
dudes may miss the gym that day cuz
they're not gonna miss their daughter's
wedding if they don't go but I've
convinced myself I will get emotional
I've convinced myself on this my
daughter's wedding
so I will get my ass out of bed at 4
o'clock in the morning and I will get to
that gym because my reasons are bigger
so my standards are higher so that's
what I think causes us to have great
standards as huge reasons number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
is live and believe is what you do
I can't transfer to you something that
I'm not experiencing myself so a lot of
times people say I want to transfer to
people leadership or I want to influence
them to buy my product or I want to grow
my company you have to really believe
these things I have to really be
consistent with your values because you
can't give me something you don't have
and so really successful people really
influential people powerful people are
congruent they actually live and believe
the things they say and do
you understand and I really think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing question
it's time to move from just watching
another video to taking action in your
life for business here we go question
number one which three people will you
commit to studying their success this
week number two your purpose comes from
your pain what is your strong why and
number three what's the single biggest
action and you could take this week to
move closer to accomplishing your goals
and only invest in things you understand
if you don't understand it don't invest
in it the number one thing you're gonna
vest in it is you your business your
brand your company then from there only
invest in things you actually understand
until you understand it that money sits
in a bank don't buy stuff you don't get
yeah and and and be very careful to put
money into places that you completely
can't explain out loud to somebody else
yeah
if you want Moorhead my lad check out
the other top 10 video Weiland hit the
link is right there next to me though I
think you're gonna enjoy continue to
believe and I'll see you this killing
success and that is that we've become
addicted to other people's opinions I
think the biggest shift in our lives the
things that makes us the happiest